Ce 1ère achat à Perpignan, il n'est pas anodin,
il est hautement symbolique.
Installer des locaux
dans des territoires
avec 1 forte présence du Rassemblement National,
c'est prendre toute notre part
à la bataille contre l'extrême droite.
Ici, à Perpignan,
nous posons la 1ère Pierre qui a pura les insoumis
dans cette bataille
et dans cette lutte contre l'extrême droite,
en montrant qu'à tous les niveaux,
tant au niveau local qu'au niveau national,
ils sont 1 mascarade.
Ils votent contre l'augmentation du SMIC,
contre le blocage de prix, contre le gel des loyers.
En réalité, ils sont autant libéraux que les libéraux,
ils défendent autant les logiques capitalistes.
Ce n'est pas parce que ils ont changé d'emballage
que le produit a changé.
Non, ils n'ont pas changé, ils ne changeront jamais.
C'est ça la bataille politique que nous impulsons.
C'est pour ça que nous inaugurons des locaux,
parce que ce sont les points de fixation
pour toutes celles et ceux
qui veulent conjurer ce futur désastreux.
Parce que mes camarades, nous avons 1 responsabilité
car à la fin, ce sera eux contre nous.
Je vous remercie.